c'est vraiment triste et m
je cherche le poney responsable je dois
préparer mon réglage sont mademoiselle
sam bird et mat
je vais justement prendre de vos
nouvelles je suis la princesse twilight
désolé pour tout ce désordre ce n'est
pas dans mes habitudes patauger dans la
crème tuer la chantilly en visuel visuel
confirmé nettoyage my little pony le
film exclusivement au cinéma le 18
octobre
génial je suis la princesse twilight
sparkle et voici mon royaume equestria
un pays plein de magie de musique mais
il est le plus important d'amity la vie
est parfaite chemin qu'est-ce qui
pourrait aller de travers
ce essentiellement les clubs que j'ai
engagé comme ça c'est sûr vous n'êtes
pas les clowns que j'ai engagé
ryan l'eau
l'applaudît des quatre favoris la
commandante
mais ici nous commencions par une
reddition complète et définitive
on vient de recevoir deux casquettes que
nos fait que j'aie jamais vus beaux
poissons s'est fait jeter c'est du
gâteau
j'adore le gâteau
[Musique]
on a besoin des aides pour sauver qu'est
ce trio qui nourrit
attrapez là maintenant
je suis là c'est l'arctique et c'est moi
que tu aimes pas si tu veux mais nous
sommes ensemble montrons à ces petits
poneys comment il faut faire comment ben
ouais l'amitié les fleurs les jolies
poneys et boulay
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais transfère pas de stress
heureusement j'ai des amis formidables
qui sont là pour moi quoi qu'il arrive
[Musique]
pink il ya du gâteau en visuel visuel
confirmés ont fait le ménage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il tony le film
exclusivement au cinéma le 18 octobre